la france très en retard pour les
énergies vertes justement l'objectif en
europe par exemple ses 22 % pour la
consommation d'électricité produite à
partir d'énergies renouvelables et bien
en france nous n'en sommes qu'à 15% on
sait pourtant que grâce aux éoliennes eh
bien on pourrait avoir de l'électricité
20% produite par les éoliennes ça
pourrait être fourni même si ce n'est
pas trop laid même si ça ne fait pas
trop de bruit et bien les éoliennes
peuvent déranger la preuve dans l'aude
où les défenseurs des châteaux cathares
ne veulent pas de ces nouveaux moulins à
vent dans leur paysage polémique léo
lamberton françoise maso c'est presque
une guerre de religion au pied des
châteaux cathares que se livrent depuis
cinq ans amoureux du patrimoine et
amoureux des énergies propres depuis
qu'une société peut installer une
centrale éolienne sur l'un des points
culminants des corbières dans l'aude la
montagne de touche et ce à quelques
kilomètres à vol d'oiseau des
forteresses vaty au moyen âge
nous sommes en plein dans le quartier
des châteaux cathares quéribus et là
tout près peyrepertuse tout près aguilar
on le voit là en bas on voit du garage
on voit la montagne noire on voit par
votant le canigou ce qui veut dire que
de tous ces points on verra aussi ses
éoliennes il ya un peu une
incompatibilité
incompatibilité de deux genres voici à
quoi ressemblera le site fin septembre
lorsque les quinze éoliennes seront
installées chacune mesurera 65 mètres de
haut malgré l'avis négatif du ministère
de l'environnement le maître d'oeuvre a
gagné la bataille parce que selon lui il
a pris toutes les précautions pour que
sa centrale ne gâche pas le décor à bord
les machines centre esthétique elle en
une architecture très particulière
agréable ensuite je rappelle que
ces châteaux sont à plus de 11 km et
tout le monde sait que dès qu'on n'ait
pas su km au point de vue observations
l'homme la lune lui ne voit pas à
distance si tout cela a été rendu
possible c'est parce que la commune de
tuchan a joué le jeu séduite par les
huit cent mille francs de taxe
professionnelle et la création de six
emplois une vraie bouffée d'air pour ce
village de 800 habitants j'ai fait que
nous sommes une commune d'essentiel mal
de bricoles nous n'avons pas d'industrie
lanouf est de passer professionnel et
ses fouilles occasion quand même nous de
pouvoir développer
c'est un projet qui reste en suspens du
pbd plus de moyens quand même comme un
département très ventée l'aude est en
train de devenir une pépinière
d'éoliennes encouragée par le
gouvernement qui veut rattraper le
retard de la france en énergies
renouvelables est de plus en plus de
voix proteste au nom de la défense du
paysage et suggère que les éoliennes
tournerait aussi bien en mer grâce au
vent du large